pirates of the caribbean dead men tell
no tales also known as the fifth pirates
movie is directed by the director of
bandidas so once again Johnny Depp is
back as Jack Sparrow searching for the
Trident of Poseidon because it can break
any curse and they just so happened to
need some curses broken and so that's
good that that thing exists and Javier
Bardem is a ghost who's looking for
revenge against Jack for something that
happened in the past and Joffrey rush as
Barbosa is one of the people that can
lead him to Sparrow
and now we're all converging and it's a
pirates movie and the first one I love
it's one of my favorite adventure movies
it was really exciting when it came out
and I remember being in the theater for
Dead Man's Chest being so incredibly
pumped and I mean people were just so
into it and ever since the first one
they've all kind of gotten consistently
worse and gracefully five is better than
the last I would say I would say it's an
improvement over the last which some
might say really isn't saying much
compared to the last one this story is
considerably more interesting there's
also a woman in this movie who everyone
thinks is a witch because she's
extremely smart and in the time this
movie takes place a very smart woman
apparently is just a witch which gets
kind of annoying at first it was funny
but then it quickly became like a really
obvious joke the joke just kept getting
recycled and recycled where every male
character would be like why are you so
smart you must be a witch get off my
boat witch and I'm like okay I get it
she's really smart and Brendan's
Thwaites character he has some history
in regards to the Pirates franchise but
I don't want to get into but he
definitely has a reason for being there
he's not just like a guy along for the
ride but this kind of brings me to my
biggest issue with this movie even
though all these characters do have
reasons for being on ships together
there's no real sense of urgency it
doesn't feel like any of these
characters have any real stakes there
are reasons for all of them being there
as I said and you do feel a sense that
there's something they all have to do
but it's just kind of like they're
moseying along through it and you never
really feel like the clock is ticking
the action sequences are
fine but they're too often played for
humor rather than excitement which
brings me to Johnny Depp the first time
around this character was just lightning
in a bottle and it was so surprising and
I've always liked him in this role even
in this dome he doesn't bother me but in
the first film it felt like he had the
reins on him still they let him go wild
but they said okay wait a second so you
got a really intense and unhinged
performance but at the same time it felt
carefully controlled here it feels like
he just has 100% freedom and he's
basically just a caricature of a
caricature and we all know what to
expect and he's funny he's likable is
definitely his signature role it's just
that there's no real character anymore
it's kind of just the big joke whenever
he's in a scene you don't really feel
that sense of humanity that you felt in
the first and particularly the second
film which is disappointing because the
film actually really wasn't all that
fine there are some good jokes
it's a entertaining looking movie
there's some really fun CG Javier Bardem
is actually pretty cool as Salazar the
CG for him was really awesome but I just
got to go back to that point there's
just really no urgency in this movie it
doesn't feel like anyone has steaks it
doesn't feel like the movies really
moving along that fast
it feels really long despite being the
shortest in the franchise so that's
saying something the pacing really drags
sometimes because there are entire
sequences where you're like is this just
so they could like have a joke why is
this in the movie I might be coming off
a little more negative than I mean to be
because I didn't mind this movie you can
have fun watching it it's certainly a
good-looking movie there's nothing that
interesting - the direction though it
feels kind of like directors imitating
other action movies of this nature there
isn't a unique spin to it gore
Verbinski's first three films even
though they were each consecutively
worse they all had a very uniquely Gore
Verbinski feel to the way they were
hound this movie just feels like every
other adventure movie you've seen before
there's nothing glaringly awful about
this film but there's also nothing
amazingly great it just leaves you sort
of middle-of-the-road when the film
finally
just pick up towards the last 20 minutes
which I actually really liked and
especially the ending which I loved by
then it's like okay I just watched the
whole film and now we're finally getting
going here I'm going to give dead men
tell no tales a C+ I think if you're a
massive Pirates fan you're going to find
some things to enjoy but I mean it's the
fifth one at this point and we've all
seen not-so-great Pirates movies already
this doesn't really surprise me I was
hoping for better though guys thank you
so much as always for watching look
forward to my transformers review this
weekend you are the best if you like
this you can click right here and get
steppen eyes
[Music]